I think what's gonna be special for the
gamers playing this DLC in terms of the
characters is not so much new characters
but it's seeing characters they'd known
before in different ways you know you're
bringing back almost all the major
characters people knew from Infinite and
and Bioshock 1 we were able to go back
to the original actors and work with
them as well you know what they call
someone who enters man's home uninvite
I'm proud to play Andrew Ryan I the door
playing it because of the writing the
writing is so incredibly good and and
the power of the character is immense
the character obviously had been so
popular with the gamers that they wanted
to see and hear more of Andrew Ryan
cause domestic trouble laughter raffle
you Fitzroy nothing but I play dayz in
BioShock Infinite I was so excited to
get the call
to come back to do the DLC just because
you know filling out the story feeling
out the character filling in the blanks
is always great if you see soo Chong
tell him atlas says he hasn't forgotten
them I play Atlas and Fontaine I was
really excited because you know it was
so much fun to do the first time what
was wonderful about the idea of coming
back is now that I understood what the
world looked like and also having seen
the characters have appointed and what
they look like and having you know that
sort of backstory was wonderful Lizabeth
tell them you can get in back say I can
get you back to rapture that played
Booker DeWitt and BioShock Infinite what
I love about coming back and playing
Booker in this is that you can take a
character that you think you've got
figured out and it has completely played
out of his story and flip it on his ear
and present the same character in a
completely different way and I think
that this is such a a fresh perspective
and not only who we've seen Booker B but
who Elizabeth thinks Booker is
I play Lizabeth in BioShock Infinite I'm
pretty excited about it you know people
have been asking are you gonna be able
to play Elizabeth and people wanted to
play her and I think being able to play
her in this last DLC it's kind of the
end and the wrap-up for the whole
Bioshock series I think it's gonna be
really cool and I hope that people enjoy
walking in her shoes and and having that
experience fans of both the original
game and infinite are going to walk away
pretty satisfied with feeling a sense of
completeness in in the end of this and
they haven't really had an abaya shot
game before